NARRATOR: Whales are big.
I know that seems like
an obvious statement,
especially while
looking at this picture.
But I know something you don't.
That giant whale, the marine
mammal dwarfing that diver,
it's a juvenile humpback.
Just wait until you see
how big the adults are.
KARIM ILIYA: Hi.
My name is Karim Iliya.
I'm a professional
photographer and filmmaker,
specializing in underwater
and aerial photography.
NARRATOR: Karim isn't actually
the one who took the photo.
He's the one getting up
close next to the whale.
KARIM ILIYA: This photo
was taken in August
off the island of Vava'u
in the kingdom of Tonga.
This is an image moments
after this juvenile humpback
whale took a sharp turn
to avoid smashing into me.
NARRATOR: That sounds
terrifying, but not to Karim.
KARIM ILIYA: It was a
playful interaction.
And there was no fear inside me.
The babies are these curious,
clumsy little creatures,
that can fill you
with so much joy
that your heart feels like it
will explode from your chest.
NARRATOR: Not every interaction
is so calm and peaceful.
When you swim with
whales, sometimes you
get a playful juvenile.
But other times, you
can find yourself
in the middle of
an all-out frenzy.
This is what happened to Karim
after jumping into the water,
not knowing that four
battle-scarred adult male
humpbacks were
fighting over the right
to mate with the lone female.
KARIM ILIYA: Out of
the depth in the blue,
four large male
humpback whales emerged.
Two of them broke
off and started
smashing into each other,
blowing bubbles, tail
whipping around.
They came closer and closer,
all the while fighting.
A five meter long tail
whipped near my face.
And the thought
occurred to me that I
would be pulverized
between these two school
bus-sized animals.
NARRATOR: But that
possibly to close encounter
didn't spoil Karim's love for
swimming with and photographing
whales.
In fact, it may have
even enhanced it.
KARIM ILIYA: Looking back on
the images that I had taken,
I see that the
whales were looking
at me, even as they fought.
It is a true testament to the
gentleness of these giants
that they would take
the time and effort
to avoid crushing this tiny
little creature before them.
The thing that I love the most
about photographing humpback
whales is the level
of interaction
that you have with them.
They are highly
intelligent creatures
with distinct
personalities and will
convey a range of
emotions and attitude,
like curiosity and
playfulness, or even annoyance.
Swimming with
humpback whales was
the most magical, humbling,
powerful experience of my life.
NARRATOR: If you
liked this video,
be sure to check out this one
on TestTube Daily about Japan's
controversial fight to
continue whale hunting.
REPORTER: The
Japanese government
has noted that whaling has long
been a part of their culture
and acknowledge that they
would likely continue,
despite the controversy.
NARRATOR: And don't forget to
click the subscribe button.
Thanks for watching.